so you
after christmas
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
um my mama mo wow it's the
show mau mau mau mau mau lawrence
just popping her head because presumably you
don't know your pup ma i actually
do know that when i was letting
you guys have that one because you
seem so excited to sing together
yeah we go long we'd never sung
that song together before oh my god
that's a first
it's impossible it's not possible i'm not
fucking the non possible burger really defensive
right now i was just adding to
what you said now why do you
have these records all flipped the other
now why
no but either way welcome to three
adam i'm scott scott and we're in
scott's home office and he has the
airwolf table here do you want to
talk about that yes this is the
first time anyone knows but we moved
all of the recording machine anyone knows
this is the i didn't even know
it but they know is now
the people listening are the first no
out of any yeah well yeah i
think anything they told me but um
we move let's see we moved the
stuff into here and b to b
to b and ah so you're in
you have this so we have the
table with all the writing and all
i know immediately after problems that all
yeah
sign that i like tea i'd like
to use my own headphones but it
doesn't seem to work out ever ever
don't know why that is i think
you have to let it go and
you have to never do that again
let it go i guess i do
but i don't i i liked having
my own way to hawaii oh yeah
they're too quiet now this is fine
this is right where this fine dog
sitting in to bring housing these are
these are coke
waters that someone made me so yeah
they say with so many records basically
like cd yeah or record ah ah
backings yeah you have them upside down
it's corn was up and i was
wondering why you were hiding that you
love you too don't you want the
cork on the top as to put
your and by the way i don't
neither of you are using them i
won't my bottle has a rubber and
it's my mom and your bottles glue
but we all know this table can
take whatever i want to put on
it that's yeah i'm saying because you
read it why start putting coasters on
this table now why are we respecting
the table i'm sorry
why are we doing that and why
isn't this part connected to this i
know this is interesting that all the
spot no longer the word of the
lord
but i and this is this is
you know the territory of why don't
they make the whole plane out of
the black box but why don't they
make any table or dresser or whatever
out of a coaster
yeah i mean this is like i
think something that has been said in
you know premium blends for years um
like the tv show
premiums blend wow
i remember i'd lay your premium blend
it was a ah the set was
like a a post-apocalyptic sort of thing
where i remember there was a big
tire
so guys money yeah there was like
so like neon signs that were askew
yeah like diameter yeah i love it
and what comedy do you remember your
material will you do it right now
was admitted i think it's right i
think it was daylight savings time bit
i think i did that for sure
yeah wow again oh my hand injury
which i will tell you about
slam into the table and heard soooo
long okay tell us about the hand
injury because i want to call body
saving spurning rather let's let's get the
hand injury the other way because you
just slapped your bad hurts so bad
i don't even know writing what just
happened do you need to meet a
pee on it yeah
i was gonna ask it before i
heard it um but what happened was
and i do want to hear about
paul's premium blend and of course the
circle back i think i told her
horse will circle need to know i
want to know more i have questions
but ok so the other night on
wednesday i was um washing a very
fancy knife that we recently acquired oh
we got lucky
thanks i never wash your knives i
know we got a new knife set
like oh look somebody's not watching their
knives anymore and the and there their
these like nice japanese knives there too
cruel thing has been wash it right
after you use your chi and put
them in the dishwasher blah blah and
we and i did have a nice
set of knives that started making their
way into the dishwasher and says why
we're
here okay that's why we have that
oh so what exact what so as
someone who because i've never been allowed
to put the knives in the dishwasher
yeah and i never allowed my to
do it but when they started getting
in there so event so then what
happened is because wow i want to
know the consequences they started to get
a little rusted oh yes smooth i
mean less you know sharp yeah um
which of course
it's good to know fixed but whatever
so we got these new knights well
the knife man comes yeah yeah it's
nice to grow there was a guy
like that in my tenor de dives
do you know what is this from
again oliver oh right duh strawberries rye
okay so it's either knives are struggling
so much i just wonderful morning
so what happened was i was watching
okay fad holly dinner she's in her
high chair we're just sitting in the
kitchen talking when i'm washing my knife
mike is in the room mics in
the room okay it was using my
knife and then it i don't know
what happened i think it flipped onto
my hand like it was so sudden
and it didn't even hurt it was
just does
and blood everywhere i was ah blood
blood blood
oh my god and then like he
got up and like was he he
i will say he was extremely fast
and what had helped me he got
a first aid kit he first had
me grab my paper towel where first
we do want to have one in
the kitchen he but i wasn't thinking
of it i put a paper towel
and then he he got the first
aid kit and basically took my hand
i almost passed out i sat
down he's pushing it together wrapping it
all the stuff holly's looking at us
like kind of scared because i'm like
i'm like she's not helping yeah yeah
and then we called two people who
couldn't come help and that they didn't
answer their phone and who we called
mary and my friend laura to watch
hollis we could lee right right and
then we all just got in the
car went to urgent care
which i'm really glad we did because
we holly loved it she oh she
was crash she had a great time
i could hear her laughing from the
room that i was still having a
lot of fun um but we got
there and and did they say if
you had been sixty seconds later you
would have lost your hand what can
i say actually it sounds a little
extreme but my finger was blue oh
and then they were like it's tied
too tight which we of course they
always say do it so tight
yeah strike me yeah but then they
were concerned she literally was like if
you left i mean i don't know
how long it would have to be
but she was like if you left
it like this you could have lost
your finger oh and like maybe if
i wasn't smart enough to go to
the urgent care i would like gone
to sleep or you know who know
but i was really terrified of that
so that's a good tip for anyone
out there don't go too tight but
i thought he was doing right i
mean we both felt very yeah you're
sound like it was probably
to cut off the yeah yeah it
was bleeding so much i'm so crazy
so it made sense but anyway it
was too tight which finger my index
fingers right here if it had been
your thumb you have a major artery
and your thumb is that true no
anyway so the i didn't ever look
at it and they the woman doctor
came in and doctor was a woman
what's bizarre
most shocking part of the story she
could operate on you because you're not
related exactly yeah and she stitched it
up i got three stitches and i
could feel it at a certain point
the light cane was wearing off in
one part of my hand and i
was like oh she's like are you
feel that and i was like yeah
and then she tried give me a
shot and i still felt it but
i will say having your whole
vagina sewn up does put things into
perspective
an abrupt subject change
and you had that as to not
have any more children i wanna make
one tighter
ah and he gets what are you
on the daddy oh my god now
what's your other injury or other finger
no this is that wait i saw
the stitches know you saw them on
this hand i just was holding like
this it's under here i just put
this band-aid on oh you oh you
just put a band-aid ah well it's
one is oh my god hurt so
fucking bad and that's something no i'm
fine but when i but i have
hit it against things and i'm like
i'm like yeah yeah it's such a
specific social craze when you hit a
cut yeah yeah especially when like it's
one of your extremities and you realize
what a gangly weirdo you are always
actually i always found no sense of
mice but no i mean i feel
that's the way
i feel like yeah with my you
know it's just like constantly hitting i
know you know i realised put on
stuff how often i wouldn't be doing
my hands a lot i'm i always
have cuts and scrapes on my hand
like i don't know where they come
from yeah sure you don't have bruises
everywhere i don't know where they come
from but anyhow i'm getting flies removed
because i went for it you're a
murderer so
so i'm getting the stitches removed on
thursday and then mike was like oh
be careful if you get the stitches
removed because it can reopen if you
like make a fist too tight or
something because he had a cut on
his hand that reopened and switches so
he's he's saying don't make a fist
and try to punch me yeah yeah
yeah he's what i'm like i can't
let these little i don't want to
stamp open no of course not oh
my
my god he said it was early
gradually and he could see a lot
of stuff in there he could see
stuff in there like could you see
stuff did you look i never looked
i can't look and i was like
really wanting to look in there during
the stitches i just i didn't look
he saw fat you have the fattest
hands i know yeah theres they're running
right now your hand is so skinny
so that's how you do it you
just
awesome blood yeah your handkerchiefs give me
i'm worried about you i mean yeah
i know um i'm trying to think
of the deepest cut i ever had
the first thing that comes to mind
is when i was a bachelor and
i was trying to assemble some ikea
furniture and ah i had to put
the wooden those little wooden dowel with
the wooden dowel in the basket who
are also like
and what i heard with the dough
as i always had to do i
had to start all over again at
some point yes of course because you
got one thing back yes sir exactly
so um i was trying to get
this tao well out of the little
hole little pig out of the hole
and watch empire what's the best tool
for that pliers probably swiss army knife
so i am
i take it this this
and i don't know i can't remember
how this happened but the swiss german
i've closed on my finger and i
saw i saw it in my finger
oh no i just stared at it
for like e a full beat like
ooh that's not good pulled it out
tons of blood didn't have i didn't
have anything
thing to deal with this i pretty
i think i just put paper towels
around and you didn't go to the
hospital or anything like that oh yeah
thousand scotch tape yeah you have a
scar i did for the longest time
i was just looking now it finally
went away wow finally went away i
was looking for many years this is
mine i don't know if you can
see it on my finger on my
pointer finger that didn't have any fingerprint
it's ah well i filed them off
but um i was i think i
was this is when i was in
theater school i was at like one
of the tech guys houses playing poker
as i recall and he had these
homemade metal stools that he had made
homemade yeah he had made them he
was like yeah i made i made
the sounds jagged yeah and that's what
he sounded like
like ah no thank you oh i
made these hey dude that's that's a
direct quote he had long hair this
is nineteen ninety i think so he
had little for long i know exactly
who you're talking to yeah i know
so i was like on perched on
the stool and i had my my
fingers wrapped underneath them like this yeah
because like trying to blast off to
eat
you're holding your scared i was like
yeah right oh no
i was just balancing myself and then
i started to fall no and i
lit i i jerked my hand up
and it totally opened my finger oh
my god and so that was definitely
a drug to warn you i made
these
that's horrible yeah that was a bad
one ah so bad why your sweatshirt
says twenty four it says eight twenty
twentieth so h when i got there
i don't know what i'd worry about
production company company because i know a
twenty four is a production company but
it is something they make like movies
and stuff it's jack bauer hwy twenty
four big hit because it's it's a
twenty
for big head we should always just
parodies of these yeah cause everyone will
get that yes it's basic switch when
eight twenty four gives them out for
yes we ever also give them to
a twenty two the same people yes
yeah let's spend all of our own
money doing that absolutely
i think the trickiest part is getting
a twenty four to share their contact
list with us but how compile heart's
gotta love them to send us the
design before they send it out so
that we are starting to go yes
we're doing thirty shirts of your shirts
so please let us know in advance
also really same time i am now
realising this is two years old nyc
was not on the list this year
oh i wonder if you remember that
list i don't know if you guys
were on this where we talked about
schindler's yeah it was like yes it
was life if only he had told
his gold watch um i've actually never
seen that comment i don't know what
it's about j k um but i
haven't ever seen it um okay there
was a list from what's that company
jack
josh a couple of years ago the
email the email lists yeah yeah this
is a i actually know you just
emailed every yeah and it was about
like the holiday gift or something like
that and then everyone was like doing
bits for four years for four years
and then certain people got really upsets
yeah i cannot be on this list
anymore
this is like imagine actually getting really
mad about it yeah i mean there's
so many it's so that happened janie
too i remember when that happened and
then it happened jimmy choo or somebody
we did it talked about yea we're
gonna
oh we've talked about this what i'm
pretty big myself first the realization
one time i talking about the same
thing i swear we might have talked
about the injuries to surfing wow i
never talked but this one just got
it yeah that's true mr yeah that's
true so we gotta chime in with
our any new story is a gateway
into old story it's true how else
we're gonna keep the conversation go away
right plus we didn't remember each other's
join the conversation we'd like to hear
from you or doing a talk back
after the podcast
where we talk about the episode and
you guys can view that on youtube
dot corn
oh speaking of the internet oh wow
what is still off twitter and really
oh yeah i'm not on this i
don't both of you quit oh i'm
so quitters it feels great because good
feels great if you're ever going to
win that way i don't need to
win i knew i was gonna win
yeah i remember
you could win the internet yeah someone
wins it every day
that's someone's crowned king and queen are
you going to read harry's book potter
prince prince harry prince harry the hairy
prince
oh it's so funny that his name
is harry and he's losing his hair
but barely is it barely funny and
also funny i mean anytime he says
hi i'm here i'm harry i look
at the back of his head and
i'm like i'm so yeah i'll use
there's some cheese he's releasing lots of
details on the internet one by one
lot of bang
backlash against him but yeah don't and
i realize they are here anymore i
don't care about him i don't care
but i think caring about i don't
care in a way that's good in
that i'll read the book now and
i won't really care i know janie
will read she likes but you know
you know what i also enjoy umm
chelsea juventus has a podcast called celebrity
but club that is all celebrity memoir
ours is kind of great because i
like celebrity memoirs but i don't always
want to read them and it's like
you just get distilled and it's really
fun like john houseman's and i like
charles groat john howard john i didn't
know john has been ah autobiography has
three i believe um and the first
one is the one that i really
love where you just goes into detail
about all of his orson welles stuff
yeah it's just
like all about that but john hoffman
was he was a he he created
julliard or not created but i think
he was one of the first teachers
there possibly and then he worked with
orson welles in the theater and then
he laid in life he was an
actor on a show called the paper
chase and he also had a very
famous in the movie basically a movie
in a very soon ah
ah not serious but a very famous
bit of commercials where he was like
they earn its smith barney yeah what
does that what was he make money
the old fashioned way a mh yeah
um i think you should explain how
charles grodin is because i know who
that is but i felt like i
made you do a whole ecce
donation that other guy and then other
people might have been okay oh but
who's charles grodin charles grodin is an
actor ah most people would know him
from midnight run on beethoven films clipper
is ah which i just saw the
other night classic heartbreak kid yeah i'd
never seen clifford know it's it's one
of my favorites i saw it opening
weekend to fight javi ma
in short was there and yeah he's
a did to talk what it was
like a correspond there's this week there
wasn't thing like it was like two
weeks ago wow today
i use right it was today you
woke up at eight am and went
to that shop an hour ago what
you just saw martin short wait right
now behind the door i wish she's
in the fireplace i wish she would
roll out of it like jiminy glick
wage many like rolled out i think
nobody yeah what you can do is
lightness that
hi mark nice to meet you would
have jiminy glick one john a sly
yeah you should you should go play
at a park with a kid there
was i i've told you about this
guy before there was a local tv
host named captain noah in philadelphia and
his captain owen is magical don't know
i mean yeah it seems like it's
already said like he you know he's
the captain is like none of the
zebras are looking i'm saying i'm
captain he wasn't that known oh it
wasn't that known and you know what
no one called that no captain which
is a real slap in the that's
what i mean yeah because you're the
guy that built the boat but i'm
also the captain he didn't train okay
no but apparent looked at him look
at me i'm the captain
um no joke so was me the
joke joke and everybody i know have
to know yeah i know but it
was funnier when he's when all make
the same joke over nine okay but
you said it with today and then
you satisfied lee smile did you say
the parrot part yeah oh no i
said zebra did it like literally sixty
seconds before i used that hurt
zebra was okay right so i was
like wait see i was gonna you
know when guys here on the boat
and you were having this site like
my today's high sierra you guys are
battling back and forth and then a
horse came over into the i'm the
captain now
what if there was
and if you said you would cause
you to somebody's question not just cut
your heart out is you know like
i'm sure that there's a hypnotist trigger
where is this your baby reminded and
actual hypnosis i tried to get hypnotized
ones to do what well on in
a show shut the fuck yeah and
it didn't take
no in ah you know i used
to go for halloween haunt at knott's
berry farm they had like niches show
and they would take volunteers and it
was this guy who would get people
to do like act like a chicken
run around the theatre and all that
kind of stuff would he actually do
act like a chicken yeah he would
do it because it's a classic and
you've got to do it like every
thing that would be anytown situation yeah
jones but why were they was doing
that so then so then i went
on stage and i was like he's
like you're you're you know he see
puts you in a train you're just
closing your eyes and then but you
are in a trance i don't know
i just was acting like it because
i was like let me go along
with this and then you're like well
then you were arms are as light
as balloons and you know you just
your arms or whatever and then he
goes around and taps people on the
shoulder who are going to participate in
the show and i didn't get tapped
so he must have known that i
wasn't or they're all plants and he
was tapping up the people really yeah
i don't know i saw one once
at a comedy club and it was
you know it's the the thing is
you're always
thinking is this real or not yeah
yeah it's not entertaining because it's just
like this just fucking well also also
if if you've been pretending like i
was to be hypnotized just hoping to
get picked or hoping it stuck or
whatever and they say act like a
chicken don't you just like go along
with it because you're embarrassed you know
like points
some people would be like so embarrassed
right oh no don't do it no
thank you you will never catch me
acting like i actually don't do that
because i grow poupon
you earn it
alright we have to take a break
we'll be right back to high yep
seem quick
and we're back and we've listened child
let's get back to these coasters i
wanna get back to premium brand so
these are music themed and we will
get back to premium yeah don't you
worry i don't i don't know i
apologize i can't remember who sent them
to me years and years ago yeah
but if they're listening some people thank
you for them there's a rattle and
hum one and you
so billy joel's the strangler um do
you think that anyone made coasters featuring
the coasters
i don't think so that would be
so disrespectful to them and i think
someone should do it now by the
way we're okay so here's a question
that can also yeah what what why
did they call the coasters that's what
i mean in our day the roller
coasters are they the coasters you put
a glass on it's less cool if
they're the coasters you political are they
just people that little i don't post
yeah think they're people
who coast through life that's less cool
to me to know i think it's
cool like roller coasters or drink coast
i think that i think they must
be the coasters like the like the
the roller but let's look them up
what do you say sure i have
nothing else to fucking do yeah i
don't care i don't care
because i gotta say i don't care
i may have done premium blend twice
i've you know what i bet you
did and i bet i saw it
i'm not chased to watch it okay
i did remember a list oh wait
what's that that was that was where
like before they were doing those comedy
half hours that was like long it
was still a bunch of comedians but
it
be longer sets i think ah huh
it would be like three comedians instead
of six or something like that like
imagine a tiny penis and then imagine
a big penis i can't and it's
in their friends yeah i can't say
i have it by the way it's
none of the ones that we know
it's so different but it's none of
the above is it the ones that
help you move heavy furniture okay wait
then let me guess yes
it's
it's oh no you can't do it
got nothing you got nothing yeah they
were dubbed the coasters because they went
from the west coast to the east
coast didn't you say i did say
something about the coast did you just
say zebra and i tuned out here
you say it's really beautiful so you
say
sanjay joshi he does this zoop is
aziz aziza z
so did we it up to give
it up give it up without looking
for kim cattrall oh my but do
ski but id like to play about
but you wouldn't
yeah when you put a d and
somebody pow wow nobody knows scooby-doo wow
i didn't you do that for your
characters i should have known that i
would film the whole thing it'd be
so funny
alright well white on your photo i
can see how many times i do
but yeah bled and i think i
only did it once i know i've
found a database of to get asked
to do it and how much pain
did you receive five hundred dollars
like was it like that kind of
thing like it was just like some
yeah it's kind of good help to
get some exposure maybe you'll get out
on late night i don't remember the
answer don't recall those questions was it
did it feel to remember if it
felt special like you were like oh
my god yes you did to be
doing taking td absolutely yeah yes yea
i mean at
that point i'd already i'd been doing
mister show haha um i think i
was i was had left the show
by that point um and i'd done
like conan and stuff so but it
was like any i i was excited
to do any stand-up on yeah what
was this what for example late friday
i
did oh yeah late friday what was
what but what was the what was
the show janine hosted oh shit what
was the name of that it was
god it was like it's not even
in this less out of bow i
don't know how would but now he's
couldn't have been that but that was
the one that i was really bummed
that i didn't get to do because
i got to start doing covering six
months too late let me see what
the name of that she never did
a second guys forgot about that show
sorry yeah i mean everything would have
been different
it was real literally every single other
person in the alternative comedy scene got
to so you did you do it
you must i remember being there but
i don't remember performing really funny because
that funny isn't that funny isn't that
funny it is
fuck anyway what name lauren show tell
us what's going on i was everyone's
holiday my holiday was good wow
wow you know really feels like a
long time ago but oh my tap
is something very personal yes this is
really personal i told you not to
ask cowell some questions comedy product products
that's exactly what it was yeah um
it was good emeralds admiral spam doing
good at it we just met her
and it was epic wide met her
before okay i just met her yeah
you really hired her considering you've met
her before you can see we had
a report yeah i could it was
she smiled big for both of you
she did child super cutie pie yeah
just really amazing yeah she's kind of
in the thing where like a two
months okay she smiles now she re
he wants to stand up like standing
up as your favorite thing where like
it's shiny nashi like you're standing up
to it so yeah assisted obviously but
she stands right and then and then
like looks at you like wow look
i'm doing and it's so cute the
first time and then like a month
in that's all she wants to do
it's like cats some new fucking material
like some
being new boys you can do it
on assisted that's a whole different yeah
but that's a while off what if
she refuses to do it unassisted she's
like she's here all through school
hey i share what is out there
and get over it that was what
i was carrying you
and i still am yeah fucking jerk
she said i would carry her all
throughout did she have a good first
christmas i would dress really cool too
and the students would like me which
and they think so
you know when i first heard about
this i was like that's so stupid
then i saw he's very cool
i wish my dad would dress cool
chevy road
because it was cool sneakers were you
saying sorry was her first christmas it
goes through sharpies yeah she does i
mean she wouldn't remember she was she
was religious there were yes she worships
was it did you come back no
he was born that day because first
god wow um i think we've gone
over that too we've talked about the
rules of christmas what happens on christmas
today christmas yep no it was fine
too there were too many people over
here i'll say and they were really
loud in r and she just was
like kind of so
silent the whole day yeah eyes wide
and then did not sleep well that
night ah til i was there ah
no there was so many people you
didn't even see teams yeah that's okay
you should come up and say hi
did you bring any on the windows
i saw you once okay i didn't
die you saw me well my whole
mask on
laura lauren did my show for i
topo right day which is a lot
of time what to do i was
ho ho um and it was really
fun you couldn't find your whole costume
okay this pissed me off so much
and i actually still found it and
i'm like what where the fuck took
a um holly threw in the trash
crash she's embarrassed well because you had
me take a photo as whoa
hope for the book yeah and korean
brought me ah elf costume and then
she was like you want this and
i was like no and then she
was like do you know no actually
i guess i will keep it because
you never know when i'll need to
wear this costume and then you actually
like a week later you have to
wear it i mean yeah a couple
months and then you asked me to
do the show
oh and i was like okay i
have the elf costume i'd even think
about looking for it so i was
like i kinda know where it is
my mind you could see it shoved
somewhere and then up it wasn't there
and i've been organizing cleaning obsessive only
the last week or so and i
still found it so here i had
a thing like that that went the
disappeared there's one place just and this
was years ago yeah and it just
occurred to me it might be in
this tiny little crawl space in a
closet yeah creepy maybe but i don't
think so because like i don't and
you haven't got up there so we
know you keep getting those
i hate that i don't promise us
you'll do it first thing and report
back i want to see your show
was so good it's so fun of
people have a chance to go they
should definitely go or watch a livestream
yeah whatever all the all the existing
shows up on vimeo right now it
was such a fun night and i
love the style of the show thank
you and you have this amazing band
and then there was a musical
act that was so good and everything
was just so fun and then you
did an amazing performance with nicole parker
that i was freaking out and i
was filming at the entire time when
you were like we have a camera
like oh you don't want the version
of the side of your head
um but it was so good i'm
so glad that you did that you
want to share with that was er
no because i mean i don't know
if people if you other people can
find it they could go find it
because it was only a little forward
go to paul i've heard that it's
great i'm lauren i'm just trying to
search for stuff on vimeo and i
could not find things that i knew
were there so i don't know if
that will work but if you go
to my web
then you can find it my life
page good investment that website right i
remember you were one of the first
people back in the nineties no yeah
you're like ninety ninety three you're like
i think the internet's gonna be the
big huge scott
this is not true and your money
i'm lying i want to seem cool
to you he's oh the other day
you did save me think the internet
is gonna be big
so does something something you would have
said you were not were you on
like aim and all that yeah yeah
oh hardcore yeah you meet any you
like friends that you had never met
imply meant for i've i have made
many friends on the internet over the
years where i we know that's been
more common but i met lauren ashley
smith
on tumblr really i didn't know that
thousand
eight oh um i so i searched
until i was very into tumblr and
i searched for um story pirates but
i joined the theater company and then
found that she had a blog and
i didn't know her and i just
like started following her blog and then
um we met an event and we'd
been following each other on there and
the
but um what a story i know
so fascinating how i told it um
i thought you knew her from as
like a child no no oh yeah
we're both adults when we were when
you met anyone um as a child
no i was kind of in a
bubble remember but
i didn't meet anyone oh because you
have that disease level disease yeah duvall
disease bubbles in your blood yeah somebody
touch you when you cut open your
hand you are able to get rid
of all the bubbles yeah the combination
is spilled and floated to the ceiling
can't touch me because one of the
bubbles might go to my brain
what a time thing that's so terrifying
how was your christmas my christmas was
good all i could think about was
having an injection and then there will
be air bubble in there yeah would
kill me right um oh that's really
scary all christmas all christmas all christmas
i thought of my fear um objections
in my rear
ceo
up here
what is really maybe you've looked at
the sea like what if in willy
wonka instead of dream this harmony thing
is like you got you need an
injection
you're but let's probably too behind the
scenes on ejection
because in the right and everybody out
it's an injection that yeah if it's
entering your rectum i don't know if
that's an issue it's like a hot
beef injection they call an objection yeah
this is great so ah so it
had a nice christmas in south carolina
huh um very colder cause i've never
had to wear a
coat there before christmas yeah i would've
thought to be chilly more in february
it gets nicole um and then i
went to the day after christmas went
to new york to do shows with
aimee mann and ted leo wow but
to leo the night before the first
show not kovind
sir hey sucks and so there was
a lot of rejiggering of what the
show was gonna be because he was
going to do like at least one
song right he's gonna do once
it's just sort of being the alphabet
so well it's public domain and you
didn't even know the alphabet no that's
why he pretended he got qubit he
mumbled through so much of it hey
are you guys do this part now
new microphone out um so ah there
was some like frantic re
re structuring of the show david were
there guests who took his place or
did the people yes well the you
did more stuff that i'd like to
answer your question well i wasn't through
with it and you try to answer
it in the middle can i be
where you're at it it's the most
obvious question you can ask huh
so ah so we did figure it
out there were people that the idea
was there was a through-line through the
show like a sort of sketch throughline
through the show oh which by the
way yeah so funny that song you
sent me oh oh my god is
so funny i at the end of
the show i sing
a song in characters keith ranieri from
the new athletes you post that you
post the cosmos pipe yeah for the
ceo the costume looked amazing i was
very proud of that but that was
so what did you show him i
would don't know i've never seen like
oh wait i'm sorry i don't yeah
you definitely don't need to show him
yeah zebra you should
you should z but you should watch
all of that tonight and yeah
i'm too busy watching half of avatar
and turning it on i started watching
grandson and found it pretty interesting i'm
emily chipsets in there was a tiktok
by hal rudnick where he's an avatar
costume and he he's talking about how
avatar people have the navy have sex
with their hair tendrils everything together yeah
yeah and it joined them together the
way he's doing it it's like this
perfectly encapsulates why i don't like that
world why i think it's dumb right
they they they tie their hair to
a bunch of stuff and yeah like
gives them bon he's just like spelling
it out like yeah that's dumb i
don't like it yeah yeah um okay
right so different part i desperately want
in the game champ oh my god
i want to be in the new
ones but i turned this i turned
this new wow halfway sweet head
i mean the third one in fifty
years did it mess up your whole
plotline for the show that he can
know we got so we got griffin
newman to play the part of ted
leo did he pick up on first
ring
why
he's game he's very game yes it's
very easy to do stuff and other
thing getting back to me about he
was just yesterday emailed about something from
three months ago oh that sounds like
me that sounds like me
um but it was about it was
about his payment for the shiver not
the show but the well doesn't that
make sense he waited through things that's
nicely time wait until the new years
jesus well that's fucked up your time
yeah fucks up my taxes griffin um
sorry i pay fifty thousand dollars like
oh she uses yeah what to be
on scott smc what
hold on a second okay that definitely
didn't come into my bank account
did you do the show actually yes
i did yes what was it addams
family but she's gonna do oh yeah
before sunrise oh did we talk i
guess we did alright um but it
was i covered a couple of ted
songs that he sang with amy normally
which ones ah both songs or no
no they were christmas socks fairytale of
new york oh yea and what are
you doing new year's eve huh yeah
yeah and have you always saying yes
my family's very singing family yeah yeah
only my little brother cannot sing my
mother would insist that he could and
he would say no i can't wow
yeah she was all like judson can
sell
my brother would say to me your
voices horrible anytime i would try to
sing and so i grew up saying
oh i've a terrible terrible voice my
brother said that to me because i
was in the in the choir the
church choir right and we knew the
the choirmaster and he once said the
only resume requires because he's mom's friend
and i believe it for a while
that's believed for so long until until
i was in a musical i got
a casta musical and they were like
well you have a solo who's always
looking the angry inch yeah the entire
show was um no but but they
were like you have a solo i
said well can i do it like
comedy can i like i'll do like
a fake opera kind of
thing and they're like yeah sure tried
and i just kind of saying what
i thought was fake opera in there
like that just sounds like you singing
and it sounds good
oh la la you got oh bigger
role well speaking of the addams family
yeah this was new years because your
family make the addams family seemed like
the manson family do you have an
uncle who's a hand
ah
i think he was a relative right
but do you have an uncle just
as you have question no i do
okay yes i do have an uncle
who's ahead but i'm saying that thing
was not a relative i know had
she was sweet she means it in
the game of thrones it's
let's write the end of the king
yeah um ah new year's eve here's
what i did because we have the
night off we did shows the engineer
wasn't with you at this point jamie
was in with his point wow you're
doing we did yeah like you wore
me down yeah we did shows some
winery the twenty eighth twenty ninth thirtieth
and january first so we had new
year's eve off haha fun here's what
i did for new year's eve not
a goddamn thanks sam azeez i sat
in the hotel i went out i
got myself a little i went to
like a nice um little grocery store
got myself some food little snacky is
a bottom line and i went back
to the hotel room and i just
fucking sat there and i have a
right to
that's so nice i watched wednesday on
i'll even watching that's fun when people
were very divided on it i was
like am i gonna hate this and
i'm like no this the fun stuff
that's fun in it is really fun
okay yeah and i want new matilda
musical that was oh yeah i've heard
it's great i though we saw girl
it's so good oh yeah yeah and
it's i really like
that show really shine the london it's
crazy me when you watch matilda both
on stage and now in the movie
i'm like how do they get so
many kids who can dance this way
that's what we are wondering where like
where did they were from verifying their
all instincts are moving so fast it's
even easier when you see it live
because it's like okay well they age
out
of it after a year and it's
been playing for years like how and
they must have it on my studies
and layout to replenish the stock of
children i keep having to fuck all
the time and that that they are
just stunting their growth yeah that's peter
from little yeah just feed them cigarettes
they they have to eat a bowl
of cigarettes sounds kinda good but it's
really good yeah so hungry for cigarettes
right now
god i'm starving i want some cigarettes
try us at nola yeah you ever
try cigarettes i tried to cigarette one
time when i was ten and it
was disgusting yeah you see i over
the years like for show or whatever
thing i've tried one but that did
not inhale um i think it's time
to break yep bye
hi everybody i'm paul and we're back
we're back and it's time for three
church sure is scott and i was
nine la la i was leaning during
the break i think nah i heard
i heard just enough to know that
i don't know what it is it's
something about law that song okay ne
this is calling it
phone emergency it wasn't nothing for an
urgency it was an emergency you were
taking care of on your phone or
it was an emergency having to do
with your phone and i was taking
care of it all my my phone
needed to go to the hospital and
needed a band-aid have you ever been
to that american girl store at the
my oh my my dog i would
just like to send to the doll
hospital when i was little i had
i had it i had
had and she never got it but
know that but that didn't exist yet
so we just had the catalog and
then they opened the store in chicago
which was extremely exciting but before that
i just got it from the catalog
when i was in first grade ahead
sweetie samantha and then i got curse
in hold occur center it will take
your sin but i called a person
but i got pen on my doll
and my mom sent it
the doll hospital i think it was
more for the experience of when they
come back they're wearing a gown they've
a balloon they have a get well
soon you pay for that or yes
you send them in but it's really
cute um you strip them naked you
know what i'm saying well i don't
think you suck jack burned a batch
that because there were yeah yeah yeah
but it was really adored
wbl and i'm very excited mike so
this is a sweet thing my grandma
had bought holly a bitty baby which
is an american girl babydoll mangling this
other section
last christmas my grandma passed away this
year but i saved the doll for
this christmas holly loves sweets so cute
it's really yeah she hug it yeah
did she know what it was or
was while i saved it till now
because she can play with dolls now
she's like she likes to put out
its features like guess what it means
you know what the brand was she
did
sally is authentic be bitty baby like
is there a human loves bridge where's
the certificate of yeah just today yeah
she kind of checked it a few
times and yeah we had to help
it up to the light and i
placed cabin in the box total loses
value yeah yeah adorable yeah wow very
sweet well this is called quipped good
submitted by pete shell
peach hell peach hell no heat airy
pete shell with shoes with shoes on
and this is based on show pete
show are you looking at me wrong
marcel the shell because i was thinking
of these pete the cat books that
i have which are a child's book
but i didn't know why you would
be talking about it i would be
talking about fritz the cat the dirty
cartoon oh my god so funny so
so funny and so sexy
i love to laugh well have you
ever i don't know if i've ever
see it probably it was like a
legendary thing when we were kids that
was like this cartoon was like rated
x it was rated movie yeah that's
so that's so nineties yeah that's so
nineties although this was the eighties but
people don't say anything is rated x
now you just go
it just is no yeah do you
remember finding out the triple x is
meaningless like there's no yeah there's there's
no there there well there's there should
be a double x this is so
filthy because there are no movies that
are double x so that that's a
real like hole in the market that
i think is an opportunity you think
there were and then somebody else was
like well put another x on there
let this guy beat me
julia misleading mine for theaters
like gimbals and macy's alright so miracle
on thirty fourth street rated x oh
i'm watching christmas vile there's no sex
but you do see santa's penis well
that's fine he's getting changed you know
it's fasten
um okay so quip a good this
is based on the cold open of
a csv type show before the opening
credits was based on that show yeah
it's basically it's like type show its
csr like quincy yeah where two of
us will play police officers and the
third player plays the lead detective there's
a dead body
the lying in front of them and
the the lead detective gets there later
after the two police officers of i
guess secured the crime scene um then
the two police officers describe how the
murder was committed and what the clues
are and once enough exposition has been
given the lead detective then tries to
cap off the scene with one a
one line quip
which sums up the crime that we
just described and i'll play ah who
song women okay okay okay so so
i'm no good at these so why
don't why doesn't paul be the lead
detective great and then so there's ah
there's a detective yeah and we are
this new police officer so i'm arriving
on the scene you're filling me in
on what happened guy and then
i will use this information to craft
the perfect quit i love that yeah
it's a lot of pressure on you
and i'm like you just i mean
divers jump right in dave christian i
didn't like one hundred and seventy times
yeah well he didn't write a single
one of them did he know those
are the only things he wrote oh
she's still happening no oh i mean
so no miami oh no i think
there's like a hundred branches of that
no the regular one they did for
paramount plus so he's just done dave
cruz david caruso he must be rich
as hell but i mean
i'm not saying he's broke yes he's
not he's done acting probably i don't
think it will never seem to like
it that much in the first place
nobody he made everyone hate him like
people despise i don't know anything about
him except for the taking his glasses
off and saying something well he was
really good on lucky on and y
p d blue he'd just been bumming
around doing bit parts and then he
got the lead in n y p
d blue
and was really imposing like really good
in it and he did one season
was like i'm gonna be a movie
star goodbye yeah i i quit and
everyone's like you can't quit they there
was a standoff then he quit and
he did two movies and neither of
them were hits and he was done
yeah but let me die thousand seasons
of tv where he's not
done apparently when he shot his last
scene he um y p d blue
ah when he was done he walked
out of the building did not say
goodbye to anyone that's so crappy the
dream that was do that for this
show you know how insane i'm gonna
do it today but you don't want
to say and that would feel after
that many years well he only did
one year of that i think that
there was even ruder actually there weird
way patinkin was on criminal minds oh
yeah here season or two and then
just left two seasons yeah and it
was like the day of the table
read of the next season and he
was driving across the country in the
opposite direction
there like anywhere are you as i'm
driving to new york
he didn't tell it he didn't tell
anyways yeah i love but he was
going through some problems at the time
we want our actors to be crazy
don't we we want it we love
oh i mean not here i'm working
with them
alright fun day of stories terrible to
experience yeah huh alright
what do we got here oh sir
we don't know you are coming oh
my god you mean you didn't know
my god i'm just a person oh
my god i'm so starstruck oh my
god what are you telling me can
i take a selfie with you maybe
later but wait wait we all take
picture of youtube and then you take
a picture of me and him like
yeah let's do pictures after okay but
you promise you you should go
don't forget and don't let me get
away from here without asking you guys
i remember last time when we we
met um that guy yeah we're now
remember when we investigated one of these
crimes and i met him but i
didn't wanna never should've let that happen
i know because it got so weird
we really thought someone was murdered with
a rubber chicken and it was just
like two hundred
yeah oh yeah no i get it
retrospect call attention to data okay buh
that was the worst part um
yeah i'm just talking what here first
of all you're much taller than i
thought you look so small on instagram
i know well what i do is
i put i put the camera really
far away okay so yeah i'm retract
because i am saving optical illusion yes
so the cameras far than everything your
house is really big know they're just
close to the camera got it okay
because i think you're having ricks and
how do you
the light you have a ringleader what
does that i've ringed like all over
the place and anyone who is not
even just in your house like in
public oh i have them stashed all
over the city that's good so when
you're buying groceries you look hot yeah
yeah um okay well we haven't put
a rough scene here i've seen this
is this fifty people were murdered this
was a birthday party
eighty where a mermaid performer was crawling
out from the ocean this is kind
of standard obviously we're on the beach
right um yeah obviously she crawled up
from the ocean called up from the
ocean performance she was it was supposed
to be like she was supposed to
take her legs off her her fishtail
off and say look i've legs i
i the curse is broken and she
couldn't get her legs off yeah and
fit her fin she yeah she couldn't
get it off so she was thrashing
around and that's all we have we've
see this whole scene of fifty people
dead and and we have this eyewitness
account of the mermaid the mermaid still
with she's here she's so alive
and she told us up to that
and we said a whole lot just
stop i know just stop right there
we need to bring in video i'm
already i said i'm like yeah i
said obviously every every person who's dead
you can see the obvious clues here
there's the each person is holding a
a cracker for the crabs to yeah
and
open crabs they also all have their
phones on video and so i think
they all were they were all recording
something yeah so they were well with
this was a party to celebrate the
turtles being hatched you know how that
happens on the issue okay so yeah
the mermaid is gonna come out and
bring the turtles into or you know
help escort them into the water and
then all these people were
and then mayhem ensues so yeah as
far as we know yeah it's now
the time to ask about pictures or
no because i'd love a selfie one
second okay
looks like what we've got here is
a wave was like oh y'all another
tick no we can't we leave and
come back i don't know stay right
there okay
i wonder if they played any music
at this party by the pixies because
it looks like what we got here
is a wave of mutilation
ah this isn't me this game i
can't find the yeah where does the
yeah happened
how far into this this is already
thirty seconds into the song
well maybe it's the beginning is the
beginning no because all it is is
like this people people and we move
people paper pp but skeptics are going
to skip the yappy where we have
to listen listen eighty minutes huh
really thing people people who put it
must happen to be a pop group
at the very end yeah your dad
is
oh okay let's just do it ourselves
it's maybe after
went to bed early yesterday after the
big battle section
look up where does the yeah happened
there also here it is wasn't that
it
i know i heard it look up
where does the yeah happen yeah just
googled that that'll make sense won't get
fooled again well you see yes i
would okay i won't get fooled again
where does the yeah how do i
not get full again by this i'm
sure there's there's going to be isolated
on youtube as well
well there's a lyric video i guess
i can scan that let's just do
another one and you just play whatever
part of the song you have yeah
exactly i think it'll be alright who's
the coppiced who's the i wanna be
the checks active okay alright alright so
i said to her if you don't
like it why don't you kick me
out and she does
she did gentlemen i'm here oh hello
sir thanks ma'am no you had to
read the mom i'm sir
sir ma'am your majesty thank you for
being here yes yeah but what what
we got going boys when we got
willed your majesty it's pretty grisly as
you can see um yeah there's ah
obviously there's ah two dead bodies here
to vix as we call them to
fix like all not too we put
the chalk outline around there and then
i added like
ah the thought bubble saying oh no
and sort of a comic strip box
around him i yeah i'm gonna add
there's four panels yeah we do we
want to make so if you talk
around here yeah oh funny that's several
that's actually very funny yeah okay yeah
so i don't know it's we're just
trying to get into the paper i
you know that's good but what do
we think happened
well ah i mean obviously they're they're
both dead yeah they're holding hands you've
bumbling what huh ha morons they're not
nice say what do you think happened
you both say how high you okay
i'll try so you're trying to get
a plea what do you think habit
oh huh
alright here's their holding hand the only
real school girls i see that obvious
in their other hands they have notes
that say i don't like you yeah
and they're dressed obviously as garbage men
so ah yeah and
and there's garbage strewn all around them
we don't know if they're garbage manner
or whether it isn't allawi today and
they have a name tag that says
just garbage yeah so and then one
of them has named his garbage the
other one has a name tag that
says man okay and we found their
feet in this trash camp yes someone
is cut off the vic
six feet thrown them away in the
trash can so they don't have feet
anymore but the perpetrator the perp i
guess we call them sometimes i'm trying
to get traitor going the traitor yeah
like trader vic's ah trader joe that's
why it's not catching trader and benedict
arnold carpet yeah
but i'm gonna hurt the burger we
go i would've thought the probably why
you are the tech day and that
wasn't even my big out
yeah ever said it was but they
didn't take the feat with them they
threw them in the trash right over
there right over there huh
sounds like some homeland
because the old omg you
hold done
sounds like somebody stinkier is on the
run
oh really
whether you just gotta wait hey hi
i'm still here instrumental for awhile don't
forget about me
yeah i don't make no sense alright
i'll try one alright your turn um
ok so where are the cops paul
hi ah do you we work together
right yeah yeah i know i'm new
i'm noom my name is liza yes
liza yeah we are so we're working
together i was assigned this
is this a lot as i'm tim
hi ho oh my god oh sir
sorry we didn't see you standing there
you're so coquettish oh i'm shy you
look like michael jackson d
do you ever get that you see
my talks do regular people say you
is deliberately doing well constantly
michael jackson because you do and i
can't tell if it's because you've done
so much plastic surgery that have deleted
your face or it's just the coven
mask oh here let me take this
sir
like liza minnelli okay hey what happened
okay well yeah it's not good there
was a murder i think a murder
yeah well he's like i don't like
like oh you under the bus but
you've been on your phone you are
only paying attention to what happened when
you walked up asked for working together
so i kind of like you haven't
really assessed the scene i was looking
up what constitutes a murder okay
well i think dead people laying in
the street that's what i found between
manslaughter and murder manslaughter is if ah
somebody was laughing while they did it
because it's man laughter yeah yeah yeah
so as you can see um you
know how we have in our quaint
little town yes these vipers grove
near the parking spots there are these
little force you know yeah you type
wearing the pass on wood ah yeah
yeah you would have tied a horse
to one of these yes you know
i'm talking about what are they called
we've never been able to find out
okay in this town jerome this is
the exact same conversation we have every
day all rooms aren't thing like roger
rome's yeah so yeah we had these
jerome's and their um there's these four
been ripped out and they're attached to
ropes that are attached to horses that
are no lengths are you gonna hopefully
it's it's not gonna get any better
lying dead over there you gotta tough
on this man here so dam and
riding the horse but he got clothesline
yeah i
bars i wanna believe somebody put there
that there's somebody was using his bars
a clothesline yeah because there's still some
shirts on it a clothesline will put
a pin in him because he's done
and the snow
our perfect i think we nailed the
whole game i found it wow found
it yeah well next send it to
us for next time
yeah where was it it's a live
version oh i just sit not that
good sound as good as the other
one i was good most mine eighty
one yeah i think we nailed it
with whatever we had we did the
best with we did last week i
think we did great yeah we didn't
feel great about right all of us
don't worry about it my wife loves
us
i love my curvy
god what i am doing whatever he
was like guys i've changed everything i'm
seeing you i feel like he probably
has made millions from being that somehow
i'm like it just feels like people
parlay shit and she made millions that
would really bother me yeah i don't
think he did well guys we gotta
go ah remember if you want to
submit your own three cheers
write to us is that how they
do it yeah freedom usa gmail write
to me stick stickley po box nine
six three new york city new york
state one no one two eight now
stick stickley was a newscaster he was
yeah he delivers the chicago land area
nilly was a nickelodeon thing he was
a to the news for nicola he
was a popsicle stick
and he didn't necessarily deliver news he
was a human i was cursed to
be a popsicle stick um i think
ultimately that did come out in the
tell all he did come on tv
when the pope got shot yeah until
i guess i'm the only one it
up at this late hour is six
don't sleep oh hell no they don't
yeah and that can get really annoying
when your date
eating one
laura it sounds like you're speaking from
experience
ah um if you want to call
us it's haha in poo yeah of
course and even i think we also
figured out that wasn't even right yeah
they'll dive yeah i think so i
don't know and then we didn't do
anything further about it but i think
you can find the number you can
call us and that's how we keep
it elite yeah ah follow us at
three dm us
essay on instagram and if you want
to hear ad-free episodes you can do
it at stitcher premium or on cpp
world it's so true but amazing i
wouldn't lie to you so thank you
for listening we love you and will
be back next week with more threesome
us by by piss pigs oh we
love you this big oh my little
pea
this pigs
only around and the piles of your
rhine ah in a pool of your
own urine urine
uh